bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde au sommaire ce soir la balle est
dans le camp des députés emmanuel macron
à renvoyer la pression sur ses opposants
hier soir le chef de l'état leur demande
de se positionner clairement pour ou
contre son projet présidentiel pour ou
contre les mesures pouvoir d'achat par
exemple les oppositions lui renvoie le
mistigri alors qui portera le chapeau de
l'impasse parlementaire c'est notre
grand débat dans un instant avec nos
invités pour toi jean luc mélenchon a
éclipsé la dynamique spectaculaire de
marine le pen aux législatives qu'est ce
que les médias n'ont pas vu ils n'ont
pas fait notre grand témoin alerte sur
une forme d'indifférence ou de mépris
pour les électeurs du rassemblement
national aujourd'hui représentée en
force dans l'hémicycle le politologue
dominique reynié est avec nous se soit
enfin nous retrouverons nos a franchi
pour leur parti pris ce soir à elsa
mondain gaba revient sur toutes les
tractations en cours à l'assemblée
nationale notamment pour les postes clés
l'international avec vincent eu lieu ce
soir le retour en grâce de mbs mohamed
ben salman le prince d'arabie saoudite
et puis le numérique de delphine
sabattier quand l'intelligence
artificielle devient consciente
d'elle-même voilà pour le menu de ce ver
installent est beau c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs le président empêché
peut-il reprendre la main emmanuel
macron demande aux oppositions de
dévoiler leur jeu en ce positionnement
clairement pour ou contre son projet
présidentiel est ce que ça peut marcher
pour sortir de l'impasse parlementaire
bonsoir terre alexandre anglade sur et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
député la république en marge des
français de l'étranger du benelux
belgique pays-bas luxembourg
députés réélus deuxième mandat bonsoir
sandrine rousseau bonsoir ravis de vous
accueillir député europe ecologie les
verts de paris élu pour la première fois
avec le soutien de la nuque ou de la
nuque ps je ne sais pas comment dire à
l'assemblée nationale bonsoir erwan
brouckère ravi de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau journaliste politique à
l'express on a besoin de votre voilà de
votre expertise est de savoir ce qui se
passe en coulisses aussi parce que
beaucoup de choses se disent of aussi
dans cette crise parlementaire et puis
bon soir julien aubert pour les
républicains vous êtes à distance avec
nous depuis depuis avignon ce soir vous
voilà ancien député de vaucluse membres
des républicains je vous donne la parole
dans un instant mais d'abord le regard
de stéphane blakowski pour ouvrir le bal
pour nous planter des décors comme
chaque soir de cette partie de poker
parlementaire si j'ai bien compris son
billet tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris
soir à tous à tout merci bonsoir à
toutes et à tous en fait mr allez si
j'ai bien compris ce choix bon si j'ai
bien compris myriam je vais vous le dire
simplement on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge la france pour l'instant est
ingouvernable combien de temps on n'en
sait rien en tout cas dans l'immédiat on
voit pas trop comment ils habitent
banques pourraient faire adopter le
projet de loi qu'elle a sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui arrive en juillet vers
demain quasiment le président de la
république s'est exprimé pour la
première fois depuis son revers
électoral de dimanche exactement il a
pris les français à témoin en disant qu'
il avait entendu le message qu'il était
prêt à négocier afin gouvernement et
donc à négocier mais en fixant à deux
conditions la clarté et la
responsabilité alors la clarté bompas
qui est clair pour le président il à
dire s'il était réélu jusque là je pense
que ça va mais ce qui est tout aussi car
pour lui c'est que ça lui donne la
légitimité bas d'appliquer le programme
pour lequel il a été lui d'autant que
sans avoir la majorité absolue il a
quand même à ma majorité relative donc
il est prêt à négocier mes histoires
c'est la carte et un stand est bien
clair il a fixé deux lignes rouges on
n'augmente pas les impôts on ne creuse
pas la dette on écoute
tous ces progrès ne saurait être financé
ni par plus d'impôts ni par plus de
dettes budgétaires et écologique
c'est pourquoi notre pays plus que
jamais a besoin de réformes ambitieuses
pour continuer de créer plus de richesse
plus de travail et innover davantage
ça fait la clarté dont j'imagine que ces
deux conditions ne sont pas acceptées
par tous bah ouais finances surtout
qu'en disant ça en parlant de cette
question de ne pas aggraver
l'endettement il vise indirectement les
deux groupes d'opposition qui sont
entrés ont plutôt envie de dépenser plus
en l'occurrence cela nous pèse bien sûr
mais aussi le rassemblement national
donc ce qui est clair pour le président
macron n'est pas forcément clair pour
jean luc mélenchon est selon lui bat la
légitimité pour mettre à son programme
pour mettre en oeuvre son programme elle
n'est pas acquise on écoute
le président ce soir à réinterpréter le
paysage politique en partant de l'idée
qu'il aurait reçu en avril un mandat
clair du pays ce n'est pas le cas il a
été élu en avril parce qu'une majorité
de françaises et de français ne
voulaient pas que l'extrême droite
préside notre république - du côté du
rassemblement national quelle réaction
alors vous savez que depuis dimanche le
rassemblement national cherche à se
distinguer de la nuit baisse notamment
des insoumis en faisant valoir que
d'abord leurs députés sont mieux
habillées ça c'est important et surtout
qu'ils ne voteraient pas
systématiquement contre les textes du
gouvernement donc sauf qu' air plus tôt
ce matin jordan dare la météo sur france
inter il disait en gros la même chose
que jean luc mélenchon attention c'est
bref
emmanuel macron dit on change de méthode
mais je ne change pas une virgule de mon
projet et je suis désolé ça marche pas
comme ça la démocratie bon alors que
peut faire le président aussi c'est
clair
le deuxième principe donc bon il
apparaît dès le début c'est à dire la
responsabilité du a fixé ses conditions
donc pas d'impôts en plus on creuse pas
la dette donc maintenant la balle est
selon lui dans le camp de l'opposition
c'est à eux de faire des propositions
pour sortir de l'impasse on écoute
il faudra clarifier dans les prochains
jours la part de responsabilité et de
coopération que les différentes
formations de l'assemblée nationale sont
prêtes à prendre
entrer dans une coalition de
gouvernement et d'action s'engager à
voter simplement certains textes notre
budget lesquels pour avancer utilement
il revient maintenant aux groupes
politiques de dire en toute transparence
jusqu'où ils sont prêts à aller bon j'ai
l'impression que ce soir c'est le
dialogue de sourds ouais c'est un petit
peu le dialogue de sourds là je suis un
peu perdu dans mes dents mais maintenant
on n'en met pas pièces dans l'année ce
que ce à quoi je voulais conclure
c'était l'idée que le président doit
passer 48 heures à bruxelles donc absent
il considère que ce temps là c'est
suffisant pour l'opposition pour faire
des propositions dont on a cru que
c'était le retour de jupiter en fixant
un ultimatum en fait non
c'est pas le cas on écoute aux divers
grégoire qui a calmé le jeu ce matin sur
france info
j'entends que plusieurs d'entre vous et
si ça passe comme ça c'est que ça a pu
être compris comme ça parle d' ultimatum
je vais être très clair il n'y a ni
ultimatum ni question de 48 heures donc
pas question de 48 heures donc on a un
peu de temps combien de temps alors ça
vous savez qu'en allemagne en apportant
la culture justement du compromis
l'alfalfa mis trois mois pour réussir à
obtenir un accord de gouvernement
combien de temps ça va prendre en france
alors là
on va justement tout à l'heure voir
combien de temps ça a pris dans trois
pays en europe parce que voilà beaucoup
beaucoup de nos voisins européens n'ont
pas de majorité absolue non plus dans
leurs élections législatives
pierre-alexandre grenade quand on bâtit
un compromis
est-ce confond la première des choses
c'est de tendre la main et de dire voilà
je viens à vous sur votre programme pour
quoi bâtir un compromis sur le programme
du président la méthode qui a été
critiquée par les oppositions et moi je
l'ait pas entendu comme ça hier soir
après chacun peut l'interpréter à sa
manière et moi j'ai entendu le président
de la république prenait acte de la
situation politique tout à fait
singulière inédite dans laquelle on se
trouve et c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
majorité absolue dans cet hémicycle une
majorité relative quand même dire que le
groupe que je représente les
majoritaires
mais ya pas de aucun groupe aujourd'hui
ne peut faire la loi seul et donc il va
falloir qu'on apprenne à légiférer et à
gouverner différemment
choses que l'on ne sait pas faire
on va devoir j'ai très bien entendu on
va devoir développer et inventer une
culture qui n'est pas la nôtre celle du
compromis celle du dialogue celle de la
discussion permanente et soutenue et
quand vous regardez les autres
démocraties parlementaires en europe que
ce soit benelux comme vous citiez mais
aussi en allemagne en italie en suède en
espagne des pays où vous avez des
gouvernements minoritaires le dialogue
est perpétuelle et permanents et donc
falloir qu'on invente de mécanique
le président est claire est ce que vous
vous êtes d'accord avec ça c'est si
clair parce qu'on n'a pas eu droit à une
campagne de projet présidentiel très
très très très clairs froid qu'a eu
des projets quand même qu'ils sont qui
sont affrontés qui n'étaient pas les
mêmes il faut le il faut le souligner il
ya un projet qui a été validé par les
françaises et les français les 10 et 24
avril dernier j'entends jean luc
mélenchon qui remet perpétuellement en
cause la légitimité de l'élection du
président la république je considère que
c'est dangereux parce que vous créer les
conditions de l'instabilité politique
est quelque part une forme de désordre
derrière mais le présent la république
est bien et bel et bien élu comme nous
ne sommes toutes et tous députés en
fonction de la participation
retraite juste voir d'achat santé il a
plein délire et plein sur l'école sur la
santé sur sur les allocations à la
source pour les on pourrait en parler
des heures mais c'est pas forcément
présent la république il a dit hier soir
qu'il était prêt à discuter et moi je
n'ai pas entendu dire ce sera sur la
base exclusive de mon projet je les ai
entendus dire je veux savoir de quelle
manière les oppositions sont elles
prêtes à entrer dans une discussion
discussions qui ne doit pas se terminer
demain soir comme on l'a entendu mais
discussion qui va prendre à mon sens des
semaines si ce n'est des mois et donc il
faut qu'on invente une nouvelle culture
parlementaire que l'on n'a pas en france
et c'est ça qu'on est prêt à faire
aujourd'hui on va voir justement
coalition ou
négociation texte par texte pour
l'instant ce sont les deux options sur
la table puisqu'il a fermé l'hypothèse
d'une union nationale cendres annonçant
comment vous vous accueillez la
proposition du président mais déjà
revenir sur ce que vous disiez sur le
fait qu'il a été élu sur son projet
personne ne conteste le fait qu'il ait
été élu ça personne ne le conteste et en
premier lieu pas journée que mélenchon
qui lui reconnaît tout à fait le fait
qu'il a été élu et moi la première
évidemment
je dis qu emmanuel macron a été élu et
qu'il est légitime en tant que président
de la république ça n'est pas pareil de
dire qu'il a été élu et de dire qu'il a
été élu sur son projet puisqu'en fait il
s'est passé en dans l'entre-deux-tours
ce qu'on appelle un barrage républicain
ce qui a perdu de manière d'ailleurs
extrêmement
angoissant j'ai envie de dire tout sens
pendant l'entre-deux tours des
législatives
puisque les éléments de langage de
l'arrêt mais on le voit là encore ce
soir c'est de dire il ya d'un côté
l'extrême droite de l'autre côté
l'extrême gauche et finalement c'est la
même chose alors et ça
revient pas oui peut te renvoie dos à
dos depuis que jean luc mélenchon et
marine le pen ça vous vous le récuser
vous vous l'avait condamné plusieurs
fois oui mais c'est un autre débat
politique dans lequel nous sommes c'est
à dire qu'en fait c'est une forme de
banalisation qu'on arrive même plus
complètement à contrer cirque moi je
fais plusieurs plateaux télé là depuis
quelques jours je n'arrive pas à
expliquer que l'extrême droite et est un
parti en soi problématique et que avoir
autant d'élus de l'extrême droite au
sein de notre assemblée est en soi
problématique pour la démocratie et ça
je pense qu'on a perdu une forme de
boussole dans cette affaire et que les
derniers éléments de langage et la
dernière stratégie d' emmanuel macron a
quand même sa part là-dedans maintenant
sur qu'est ce qu'on va faire dans
l'assemblée eh bien on va faire quelque
chose qui est tout à fait
révolutionnaire qui s'appelle faire
fonctionner le parlement et ça oui je
sais ça on n'a pas complètement
l'habitude en 5ème république en france
cirque le parlement en général et à une
majorité extrêmement nettes qui suivent
la majorité présidentielle et donc il
n'y a pas de danger il n'y a pas de
compromis leiria passera texte par texte
vous verrez elle te ment font à chaque
fois dans les mails exactement
chercherait une forme de compromis pour
pousser vos propositions vos amendements
c'est ça la méthode pour laura
fonctionner le parlement telle qu'ils
doivent être c'est à dire faire des
propositions ce qu'on ne connaît pas
encore dans l'équation et qui me semble
être une inconnue de taille c'est avec
qui emmanuel macron veut-il commencé à
discuter puisqu'en fait là bas on a
compris qu'il voulait discuter vous
allez nous le dire avec tout le monde
sauf avec jean luc mélenchon et marine
le pen voit l'affairé mais ça nous
sommes en dehors de son champ d'accord
possible et moi je rappelle que vous
associez europe ecologie les verts oui
bon bah on a fait un groupe qui sait pas
on n'a pas faim on a compris qu'il
fallait pas forcément discuter avec les
insoumis mais pas la porte n'était pas
fermée
ils cherchent à créer la division et il
n'y aurait du mal à le faire au sein de
lannux mais ce que je dit juste c'est
que là il va falloir qu'ils clarifient
aussi son jeu parce qu'en fait c'est pas
possible de nous renvoyer tous et toutes
à la même
a la même responsabilité si d'un côté
tous nos amendements sont rejetés alors
que de l'autre côté tous les amendements
aient l'air par exemple au hasard sont
acceptés alors justement je vais aller
voir julien aubert et puis je vous
redonne la parole juste après j'ai les
aubert comment on avait pu blique un
réagissent par rapport à 7 à cette
méthode de négociation au fond
dites-nous jusqu'où vous êtes prêt à
négocier réforme paraît forme texte par
texte calé au fond les quels sont les
contours de votre voilà votre pour votre
contre sur l'ensemble du projet en fait
c'est ça qu'on comprend ce soir
d'emmanuel macron
la position des républicains avait été
assez clair c'est à dire que on ne
souhaite pas faire partie du
gouvernement ne souhaite pas dans un
pacte majoritaire
en revanche comme on l'a toujours fait
lors du dernier quinquennat nous sommes
prêts à voter lorsque des choses
viennent sur nos orientations et en fait
le président de la république son
problème c'est le scellier en même temps
c'est pas que ce soit il nomme un
premier de droite qui ferait une
politique de droite et dans ce cas là
bas il ya plus de chances que les
républicains et même le fn par exemple
s'il venait à juguler l'immigration j'en
sais rien votent pour lui soit ils en
après-midi de gauche et dans ce cas là
bas entre ensemble et la nuque bailly
lors est arrivé notamment à générer
d'abord sa majorité complètement de
façon beaucoup plus pragmatique texte a
pretext prenons un exemple le pouvoir
d'achat vous votez chèques alimentaires
vous voté l'augmentation du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires vous voté la
prolongation des aides des aides sur sur
l'essence les 18 centimes d'euros le
litre est ce que est ce qu'on peut avoir
une réponse claire sur ces mesures
précises en fait sans l'appui d'autres
inverse c'est à dire que vous allez
avoir des propositions qui vont et demi
soit à part le groupe l'est républicain
en disant par exemple nous considère que
la hausse du prix du carburant eh bien
il faut le dire et la prendre en compte
non pas seulement pour les gros rouleurs
qui ont certes hâtive du véhicule mais
l'élargir à des publics par exemple les
bureaux ou par rapport aux pas seulement
par rapport au pouvoir d'achat
revenu et on verra ensuite la réaction
de l'exécutif de chronopost
bon c'est drôle parce que ce soir au
fond c'est pourquoi pas négocier à
condition de prendre mes propositions on
est dans le dialogue de sourds vous avez
sentiment que depuis et l'allocution
présidentielle des choses nouvelles les
avancées ont été permises ou pas j'ai
pas l'impression du tout d'ailleurs pour
bien ce que vous disiez vous deux un de
vos collègues députés renaissance me
disais il ya encore quelques heures on
ne veut pas discuter pas avec la nuit ps
ne veut pas discuter que là elle est
fille ni avec le rnd là ça a l'air quand
même assez claire de votre part ça avant
de la tuer deuxièmement il ya le présent
la république a parlé de clarté et il a
ajouté tout de suite clarté sur le fait
de mettre en oeuvre mon projet
présidentiel qui a été choisie par les
français en avril dernier donc on peut
aussi se dire que leur point de vue de
l'ouverture des mains tendues on est sur
une main tendue très petit pour le coup
et deuxième chose qu'on a un peu oublié
mais hier le président république a dit
il nous manque une trentaine de députés
pour avoir une majorité d'avis or pour
le moment en tout cas on est à 44 donc
ça fait quand même du chemin trentaine
qu'est ce que ça veut dire il faut aller
chercher donc du côté de socialistes de
sociaux démocrates qui ne sont pas
affiliés du ps ou alors celle et l air
et peut-être quelques udi par ci par là
ça veut peut-être dire que le présent
d'un public a déjà commencé déjà des
tractations avec certaines personnes et
que maintenant il va falloir que j'ai
cru deux fils sont déjà passés
individuellement notamment à des
républiques à une justesse par exemple
n'aurait pas du tout envie de devoir
repartir en campagne en cas de
dissolution évidemment alors le problème
c'est que l air est plutôt réfractaire
effectivement on l'a vu à des à une
coalition déjà et même peut-être à
participer et voter certains textes
puisque c'est plutôt une frange soit
disons une ligne plutôt plus dur soit
une frange aussi provoquer qui n'accepte
pas ça du tout et effectivement
elisabeth bornes je crois d dimanche à
vue avec son équipe qu'elle était point
par point personne par personne les gens
qui étaient capables de convaincre soi
pour une dizaine coalition plus générale
soit pour voter des textes de façon plus
momentanés alors
en fait c'est là sa manière de tendre la
main qui pose problème
très clairement ce soir tous toutes les
oppositions d'ailleurs y compris les
écologistes les socialistes on va
écouter tout de suite boris vélo puis
vous répondrai dans l'ensemble juste
après parce que au fond il dit à peu
près la même chose que vous sentez vous
c'est rassurant hier il nous a
interpellés en nous disant à quel
compromis les groupes parlementaires
sont prêts pour appliquer mon programme
d'abord lui rappeler qu'il a été élu -
sur son programme que sûr que contre
l'extrême droite et que nous avons voté
à gauche pour pour lui il est donc
d'abord de sa responsabilité de dire à
quels compromis lui il est prêt nous
avons des propositions à faire sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui est la première des
urgences est il prêt à les considérer et
sinon le travail se fera au parlement
plutôt que au gouvernement voilà c'est à
emmanuel macron de dire à quoi il est
prêt à renoncer sur son programme
il s'agit pas de faire entrer des
nouvelles mesures il s'agit pas de il
s'agit pas de renoncement ni d'un côté
ni de l'autre c'est pas ça la culture de
la coalition où la culture du compromis
si on exclut la coalition si on va texte
par texte
cette culture là elle exige que chacun
fasse un pas l'un vers l'autre et c'est
pas vendre son âme ce n'est pas renoncer
à ses valeurs que d'être capable de se
dire que sur un texte sur une série
d'amendements on va être capables de
s'entendre parce que ces mesures vont
dans le bon sens et qu'elles sont dans
l'utilité du pays moi je crois qu'il
faut changer de logiciel intellectuelle
et politique pour le comprendre
travailler ensemble au-delà des clivages
n'impose pas de renoncer à ses valeurs
et à son idéologie c'est très clair
clair prenons un exemple ensuite nommé
ensuite ensuite réclame ou reculer d'un
ou de plusieurs des choses parce que
j'ai entendu dire que on met un signe
égal entre le rassemblement national et
la nuit baisse c'est pas le cas et moi
je le dis très clairement à votre micro
il n'y aura pas d'accord ni de travail
ni de près ni de loin avec le
rassemblement national en aucune manière
et moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on
puisse construire à l'assemblée
nationale une coalition de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les forces
républicaines et européennes c'est à
dire que quand vous prenez le parlement
européen aujourd'hui vous avez un groupe
central qui s'appelle le groupe
renaissance renew près comme le nôtre
ici à l'assemblée nationale vous avez
les écologistes vous avez les sociaux
démocrates vous avez la droite modérée
républicaine et ses députés européens
qui ne partagent pas toujours les mêmes
visions politiques arrivent à s'entendre
sur des textes pour faire avancer la
construction européenne je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous ici à la sombre et à
l'assemblée nationale au delà des
clivages et des différents accords
parfois nous nous sommes vus assigner
bien qu'ils voient qu'on a ri rhodia
progression dans un duel nu pérenne vous
auriez appelé à voter la nuque mais oui
bonsoir mes baskets
concerne c'est très clair mais mes dents
encore une fois dans la nuit vous avez
beaucoup de personnalités différentes
mais moi il n'ya pas deux y a pas de
candidat il n'y a pas de bain quand le
candidat soumis si vous les invitez
corps bin on sait
déjà où je ne patine et que notre alors
moi je voudrais savoir sur les réformes
concrètement tout le monde s'était
étonné du fait de l'absence de mention
de la réforme des retraites hier soir
dans le discours présidentiel
est ce que comme marine le pen qui dit
clairement les 65 ans et enterré on en
est là est ce que le fait qu'il n'en ai
pas parlé ça veut dire qu'il est ouvert
à supprimer cette mesure d'allongement
d'âge je vais pas m'exprimer sur ce
qu'elle préside la république dans son
esprit sachant que ne pas discuter avec
lui qui l'a pas exprimé clairement hier
soir mais je ne vais pas faire de la
réforme des retraites une réforme qui
serait à part et en dehors de toutes les
politiques publiques et les réformes
importantes que l'on doit mener à partir
du moment où vous dites que vous êtes
ouvert à la discussion vous est ouvert
aux compromis où vous êtes ouvert à la
coalition évidemment que tout peut se
discuter les 65 tout sera sur la table
c'est ça la culture de la coalition du
compromis après les uns et les autres
viendront avec leur proposition ne
viendront avec les nôtres et après on
discute et on voit comment on avance
mais moi ce que je veux c'est que les
cinq années qui sont devant nous ne
soient pas des années gâchées ce doit
être des années utiles au pays et pour
cela faire du compromis cendre au sort
l'a en fait il ya quand même un certain
nombre d'ambiguïtés alors déjà merci de
rappeler ça après je rappelle quand même
que lé finit pas d'extrême gauche à un
déficit la gauche l'extrême gauche c'est
le npa c'est le parti ouvrier c'est
vraiment
mettre quand même les choses un tout
petit peu en place ensuite la deuxième
chose c'est que
en fait typiquement par exemple sur les
retraites ya quelque chose de très
intéressant qui est que à priori non le
projet de loi sur la retraite assure le
pouvoir d'achat il va y avoir quelque
chose sur la retraite qui est
l'indexation des retraites sur
l'inflation des pensions de retraite sur
cette indexation
donc en fait pour le dire de manière
claire c'est que les retraites vont
augmenter en même rythme que l'inflation
elle voté oui mais là avec la consigne
qu'a donnée avec les contraintes comme
un cadeau neimann elle m'a confié de
dire pas de fiscalité supplémentaire et
pas de dettes supplémentaires la mesure
va coûter plusieurs milliards d'euros
probablement même au delà de 10
milliards d'euros comme on fait bien où
est ce qu'on va chercher cet argent donc
prêt en fait c'est ça le sujet c'est
quelle pourrait être en discussions
c'est de connaître quoi si on trouve des
économies en face c'est ce que vous mais
non moi de lannux je vous dis par
exemple il faut augmenter la dernière
tranche d'imposition il faut augmenter
la tranche d'imposition des firmes
multinationales qui par ailleurs
optimiste fiscalement de manière massive
voilà donc c'est tout un programme de
gouvernement que vous écrivez twin
semble
et ce que je veux dire aux gens qui nous
regardent c'est que là il va se passer
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent probablement dès débats
parlementaires qui vont être extrêmement
tendue probablement même allez-vous
désespérer de la démocratie et des
députés en disant que ça va ressembler
peut-être à une cour d'école peut-être à
quelque chose qui n'est pas digne de la
république est ce que je dis à mes
concitoyens et concitoyennes c'est que
là il va se passer quelque chose que
nous ne connaissons pas en france qui
est cette fameuse culture du compromis
et ce fameux débat démocratique le
parlement c'est le coeur battant de
notre démocratie il va retrouver tout ça
tout ça sa raison d'être et toute sa
place dans notre démocratie et donc il
va il ne va pas falloir désespérer de la
démocratie au contraire il va falloir
prendre ça comme une évolution majeure
parce que enfin cette cette instance va
servir à quelque chose qui va être de
faire de la politique et de trouver les
alliances nécessaires pour avancer je
n'ai aubert vous partager au fond
l'optimisme de sandrine rousseau on va
entrer dans une forme de parlementarisme
nouveau
qui prendra du temps certainement mais
qui peut être une opportunité
non je crois qu'on paie il est très
mauvaise idée les vingt dernières années
sur la vème république
on paye le quinquennat qui avait été
inventé pour empêcher la cohabitation
aurait à des résultats à on paye tous
ceux qui proposaient la proportionnelle
aujourd'hui vous avez les faits la
proportionnelle avec un spectale
majoritaire oui bien ce que ça pose
comme comme remblais le heureusement n'a
pas voté et français pour pouvoir voir
ce que c'est effectivement un parlement
sans majorité on paye leurs en même
temps et qui a fait que finalement il
n'y a plus eu d'idées et maintenant on
se retrouve finalement avec un parlement
très divisée où on ne sait pas quelle
orientation politique donné et on paye
aussi le fait qu' il n'y a pas eu de
campagne présidentielle est en fait nous
avons à la fin des élus mais il n'y a
pas de campagne présidentielle sur les
idées il n'y a pas eu de campagne et
législatif équitablement et donc du coup
tous ses élus se disait maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on fait et on va perdre de
long - alors qu'on sait que nous avons
sur les bras une crise majeure des défis
gigantesques
voilà pourquoi j'ai trouvé un peu
irresponsable de la part du président la
république d'écarter l'idée d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale
quand j'entends mon collègue mon ex
collègue monsieur anglade parler
finalement de réunir les européennes si
vous avez déjà fait ça sur la quatrième
république ça s'appelait la troisième
force c'était un parlement où on voulait
empêcher les communistes et les
gaullistes d'accéder aux responsabilités
tous tous les autres s'étaient alliés
c'est là que vous étiez favorable à
cette hypothèse et il a clairement
écarté expliquant alors c'est
l'entourage du président qui explique
que l'hymne national c'est souvent la
guerre c'est des contextes terrible pour
le pays qui nécessite de de rassembler
toutes les forces de la nation un tout
petit une toute petite question erwan
bryckaert avant de vous montrer un sujet
justement sur le travail des coalitions
nos chez nos voisins européens en
coulisses à quoi un point on pense on se
dit qu'est ce qui peut se passer est-ce
que c'est gouvernable texte par texte
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que 10 des
conseillers les proches du président bon
en tout cas moi pour avoir eu un
ministre il ya un an il disait ça à
prendre du temps puisque emmanuel macron
adam 1 une sémantique trême acronis tu
lisais événement n'a pas crantée seule
cette vision du parlement utile dans
lequel on discute c'est une pression
qu'il n'avait pas eu et donc forcément
pour que les gens s'y habituent grosso
modo petit à petit ça met un petit peu
de temps puisque on peut le dire
emmanuel macron considérer quand même un
petit peu avec sa majorité absolue en
tout cas avec ses alliés le parlement un
petit peu comme une chambre
d'enregistrement et il fallait que ça
aille vite c'est richard ferrand le
disait de temps en temps
emmanuel macron veux que ces réformes
avec très vite mais quand ça discute
ainsi obtenir des ordonnances c'est un
peu long c'est du mandat là on est on
est comme un petit peu perdues je trouve
dans la majorité sur les solutions à
tous et puisque le président l'a dit
soit on votre ex partex on trouve une
coalition les républicains ne veulent
pas de coalition et les autres formats
ne veulent pas ils donc là pour le
moment on est bloqué mais certains me
disaient aussi peut-être que il fallait
passer par décrets pendant l'été ne pas
proposer de projet de loi puisque comme
vous disiez mon âme rousseau ça va
peut-être être la guerre cet été et
effectivement je pense aussi une
répétition et je pense
oui j'ai la démocratie je pense
qu'effectivement les légendes verrons ce
que c'est qu'aussi des vraies
discussions des vrais compromis à
l'assemblée et puis on est aussi au
coeur d'une bataille de communication il
faut le dire vous mettez la pression sur
le président de la république et de
président de la république il ya dans
son allocution prend à témoin les
français aussi en disant à ses
oppositions moi je pars deux jours à
bruxelles je voulais c'est peut-être
même une semaine puisqu'il paraît loin
un long marathon à l'étranger je vous
laisse régler ça et devant les français
je vous demande de faire preuve de
responsabilité dont on a deux logiques
fait qu'ils seront joue l'opinion contre
les oppositions fin de règne sur deux
choses importantes à mon sens c'est que
là on ne parle pas depuis le début du
gouvernement ce qui est fascinant c'est
à dire que et c'est pour ça que il n'a
pas entendu la critique fondamentale qui
a été adressée à emmanuel macron et
scrutin après scrutin cette critique lui
est adressée qui est cette présidence
trop jupitérienne trp incarner trop
personnifiée et là c'est comme si le
président et le parlement discuter
ensemble sans qu'il y ait cette
médiation qui s'appelle le gouvernement
avec à bedford va recevoir les chefs de
président de parti elizabeth
cité par le président ma république ce
qui est quand même tout à fait fascinant
bon et puis la deuxième chose c'est que
oui on devoir assister à cette culture
du compromis qui n'est pas la cour de
récréation et qui est précisément la
construction d'une démocratie mais ce
qu'on ne sait pas et je le répète c'est
avec qui c'est à dire comment en fait
quelle est l'orientation prise par le
gouvernement et le fait que emmanuel
macron dise je m'en vais 48 heures et je
vous laisse faire ben ça n'est pas son
rôle et 2 donc c'est au gouvernement de
nous pour l'instant c'est le chemin et
de parole a atteint peuvent vérifier
cette idée de facile mathom c'est quand
il revient les négociations pourront
commencer à prendre le temps justement
cette question du temps vous avez
compris qu'elle est allée centrale
voyons chez chez nos voisins européens
belgique italie allemagne et bien
combien de temps ça prend de trouver des
compromis regardez ces signes et nicolas
quad ou
si en france l'idée même d'une coalition
de gouvernement paraît si lointaine nos
voisins européens sont rompus à
l'exercice
en allemagne les députés sont élus à la
proportionnelle
le parti arrivé en tête et donc chargé
de constituer une majorité c'est le
début de longues discussions avec
l'opposition se sont mis d'accord avec
qui ça pourrait se faire
appel les négociations d'une colley
pollution ou l'achat points
de son parti des tractations qui peuvent
durer longtemps olaf scholz le
chancelier allemand a mis deux mois et
demi à former son gouvernement
mais il existe encore pire la belgique
par exemple est restée près de deux ans
son gouvernement faute d'accord entre
les parties pendant 16 mois clairement
il n'y a aucune réforme qui peut être
entreprise il ya même pas de nouveau
budget le gouvernement est obligé de
travailler sur le budget de l'année
précédente qui avait été voté par le
parlement et ce qui pose un certain
nombre de problèmes et il n'est là que
pour gérer vraiment l'urgence en italie
la nécessité de coalition donnent lieu à
des alliances de circonstance qui
paraissent parfois contre nature le
gouvernement de mario draghi regroupe
des députés qui vont de la gauche à
l'extrême droite un large spectre
politique et des accords programmatiques
âprement négocié qui peuvent parfois
déstabiliser les électeurs
magaly solier médias auraient peut-être
que j'aurais aimé une approche moins dur
sur l'immigration
un problème de ce genre doit être résolu
avec un discours plus modéré au mot
d'eilat au sein de l'union européenne 19
pays sur 27 sont gouvernés par des
alliances entre partis
bon ben voilà c'est le début de très
longues négociations
c'est ce sont des modèles trois mois
deux mois + moi je crois qu'on est dans
un temps quand même deux défis
extrêmement important sur le pouvoir
d'achat avec l'inflation qui revient
très fort et la guerre qui qui frappe
l'europe la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique était une priorité politique
absolue et donc on a intérêt à aller
vite mais votre préférence est une
logique de coalition trois mois autour
de trois quatre cinq réformes ou d'aller
comme ça un peu en naviguant à vue texte
prétexte ans qu'il faudra aller chercher
des des majorités d'idées et des
majorités de projets différentes ce en
fonction des textes qui arriveront par
là c'est évident que sur les questions
économiques on aura peut-être plus de
sensibilité d'affinités avec le groupe
l'est républicain et quand on embrayera
les réformes importantes dans la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique ça se
fera avec les écologistes et les
sociaux-démocrates de cet hémicycle je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'il faut être
capable de le penser d'accord avec ça dd
géographie variable de majorité le cri
titre avec les verts et les allées
retraite avec les bleus dlr emmanuel
macron il dit pas de fiscalité pas de
dette ni de dette écologique
supplémentaires un fassi le texte sur
l'économie accroît par exemple les
niches fiscales sur le kérosène sur le
carbone et ça pique après on fait un
texte sur le climat ça va pas le faire
oui mais pour l'instant c'est ce que
vous avez fait pardon mais parce que
vous avez fait donc en jeu ça va être ça
et encore une fois ça va être un moment
de vérité du parlement c'est à dire
qu'on va enfin regarder les textes et la
cohérence de ses textes les uns après
les autres et peut-être que finalement
et bien ce sera le premier jour d'une
nouvelle démocratie en france et qu'on
arrivera à sortir par le haut de quelque
chose qui fait que les français se
désintéressent complètement de la
politique ou tourner le nom parfois de
manière violente même à la politique là
on va retrouver le sens du débat de
l'altérité des différences oui nous ne
sommes pas d'accord sur des choses et
pourquoi pas parce que nous portons des
modèles de société différent je n'ai
aubert peut-être une dernière question
le fait que emmanuel macron que vous
connaissez bien vous avez partagé les
bancs de l'ena avec lui ne se représente
pas est ce que ça peut être une bonne
chose justement pour créer dans notre
pays cette culture du compromis y
compris du côté du côté de l'exécutif
non je ne pense pas parce que ça va
plutôt l'affaiblît aux etats unis c'est
ce qu'on appelle la livebox à dire un
canard un canard boiteux étant donné que
en fait je crois que le
seul outil faible dans cette coalition
c'est ensemble parce que les successeurs
des manuels macro surtout dans un
contexte où il n'y a pas de majorité et
risquent très rapidement de vouloir s'en
affranchir et donc le risque c'est
qu'ensemble secours pas un jour entre un
ensemble de droits tels ensembles de
gauche
et bien voilà ça simplifiera les tâches
peu la tâche parce que finalement c'est
ensemble qu'ils bloquent le jeu sur une
droite et une gauche forte majorité dans
ce parlement bon je rappelle quand même
que ensemble à la majorité relative dans
les lycées claironne poker vous aurez le
mot de la fin la stratégie du
pourrissement on entend parfois ça en
coulisses au fond avant de dissoudre on
prend les français à témoin et on leur
montre au fond ce que c'est qu'une
démocratie bloqués ça peut être ça le
scénario c'est possible on ne peut pas
dire à voter spectateurs qu'il dit la
dissolution est prévu les ducs a
envisagé par certains membres de la
majorité par certains cadres dans six
mois dans un an peut-être ce qui est sûr
c'est que emmanuel macron en fait à
comme deux grandes obsessions c1 laissé
une marque dans l'histoire surtout après
deux mandats et surtout que son deuxième
mandat n'engendre pas l'arrivée du
rassemblement national à la tête du pays
et or là la situation lui permet comme
d'inventer quelque chose on ne sait pas
quoi je ne sais pas quoi je ne sais pas
quelles seront les modalités techniques
mais inventer quelque chose justement
pour laisser une marque importante et
peut-être un renouvellement défense et
la nouvelle méthode qui dans ce pays
roannais qui s'imposa oui on mais bien
un chemin détourné qui n'avait pas prévu
merci infiniment bon courage à j'ai
envie de dire puisque ça ne fait que
commencer et le brouillard est encore
assez épais il faut dire merci à vous on
va accueillir à présent notre grand
témoin dominique reynié politologue il a
beaucoup travaillé sur la montée des
populismes en france et en europe et
puis depuis quelques jours il a la dent
dure contre le système médiatique
responsable à ses yeux d'avoir donné
trop de place à jean luc mélenchon et
d'être passé ainsi complètement à côté
de la progression spectaculaire de
marine le pen alors si on invite ce soir
c'est pour comprendre comment le
rassemblement national à pie x 11 son
résultat de 2007 six boeing
si on vous invite dominique reynié c'est
que dimanche dernier s'est produit un
fait politique majeur il est 20h vous
découvrez le visage de la nouvelle
assemblée nationale les estimations
nombre de sièges le résultat sans
précédent du rassemblement national aux
législatives le rassemblement national
89 sièges 89 députés arrivés hier à
l'assemblée l'image historique et
volonté politique affichée par marine le
pen nous sommes préparés à cela depuis
de nombreuses années vous allez voir que
nous allons abattre un travail très
important
différemment de ce que vous avez
l'habitude de dire sur nous dominique
reynié le politologue que vous êtes
professeur à sciences po et directeur de
la fondation pour l'innovation politique
cette montée de l'extrême-droite de
l'analyser depuis de nombreuses années
en france et en europe et à vos yeux une
nouvelle étape vient d'être franchie
nous avons désormais un arn qui n'est
plus simplement un parti pour
présidentielle et puis on disparaît il
devient partis parlementaires on sait
pas si des parlementaires je crois par
un est en tout cas la partie qui va
compter au parlement alors dominique
reynié éclairez nous cette
institutionnalisation du r n quelles
pourraient être ces conséquences est ce
une bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle pour
la démocratie
bonsoir dominique reynié on sortirait
vainqueur ravis de vous accueillir lors
cette question je sais qu'elle peut vous
agacé parce qu'elle elle elle est en
ferme un peu le rn dans une question
morale et en même temps bonne ou
mauvaise nouvelle pour la démocratie de
pays qui à voter pour marine le pen à
plus de 40 % à la présidentielle
il est véritablement représenter
aujourd'hui
sans proportionnelle à l'assemblée alors
est-ce qu'il faut sont félicités pour la
démocratie ou sans m'inquiéter en fait
les deux dimensions sont sont recevables
et peuvent aller ensemble même si ça
paraît un peu paradoxale d'une certaine
manière il serait tout à fait
inacceptable
qu'un parti qui réalise de tels scores à
l'élection présidentielle est désormais
aux élections législatives soient pas
représentés correctement ce serait une
idée qui tuerait même l'idéal sur lequel
se fonde les personnes qui peuvent
critiquer ce parti et puis un aspect
problématique parce que ce sont quand
même des phénomènes politiques c'est
populisme de gauche ou de droite surtout
de droite par leur puissance et en
espèces ici le rassemblement national
qui n'émergent pas ça en cause
ses causes pour ne pas être trop
simpliste mais relève quand même
d'une incapacité des pouvoirs classique
à répondre à des attentes à résoudre des
problèmes à considérer même des
préoccupations comme étant recevable à
ne pas stigmatiser les électeurs voyez
donc c'est quand même nécessairement une
manifestation pathologique de la
démocratie pourquoi personne n'a rien vu
venir
c'est neuf députés
alors on n'est pas surpris du résultat
quand on observe çà dans le détail parce
que ça fait un moment qu'il ya une
progression vous avez rappelé quelques
chiffres et au fond ils sont très
parlants eux mêmes mais moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que vous rappeliez les
chiffres en 2022 au second tour marine
le pen fait plus de 41% son père faisait
18 % en 2002 son père s'est présentée
pour la première fois en 1988 très
longtemps maintenant il a fait 14 et
demi pour 195 effet 15% je vais pas
multiplier les chiffres bien sûr mais
depuis ce temps là ça n'a pas suffi ce
fut un temps incroyable ça n'a pas suffi
pour qu'on se dise il faut absolument
nous concentrer sur ce phénomène voir
qu'ils sont ses électeurs essayer de les
comprendre et de leur ré prendre parce
que ils font quelque chose
de problématique en soutenant un partis
anti-système protestataires d'ailleurs
peut-être que ça ira est en train de
passer sur le caractère anti système
mais ils font quelque chose de très
important qui est de passer par les
urnes ils votent ils ne cassent pas il
ne s'oppose pas à la sécession pour
l'heure pour la région dans la
convention démocrate et je vous ai
entendu depuis quelques jours vous avez
la dent dure contre ce que vous appelez
le système médiatique qui aurait laissé
trop de place à jean luc mélenchon il
presque hypnotiser fasciné c'est ce que
vous dites alors oui le personnage je
vous reconnais que la formule système
médiatique n'est pas une formule
heureuse n'est pas une belle formule
j'ai pas trouvé une autre façon de
désigner cette espèce de déco que le
monde médiatique
produits
tandis que son devoir est de représenter
la société française d'un filtre il ya
un filtre ya un filtre c'est un filtre
morale c'est un filtre militants aussi
et il y a cantonné oui moi je les médias
quoi sont de gauche prg en vous oui il
ya une à une il ya une vraie là une
vraie préférence pour pour le discours
de gauche quand on est moi dans ma
situation j'ai chose quand même non mais
c'est tout c'est une vraie c'est une
vraie loi non écrite non pas que ce soit
une obligation mais c'est très net on le
voit à de multiples sujets qui ne sont
pas traités ou qui sont pas traités de
manière positive d'autres qui sont
traités de manière positive qui pourrait
être traité d'une autre façon c'est ce
système médiatique nos fonds occultes
une forme de nos réalités ou qui ne
laissent pas leurs compositeurs de voile
à la possibilité aux électeurs de du
rassemblement national de se sentir
représenté la réalité présente pas leur
souffrance si vous voulez moi c'est ce
que j'appelle la double crise de la
représentation on parle souvent de la
représentation politique mais sur le
plan médiatique c'est vrai aussi
simplement un exemple
françois ruffin pendant sa campagne a
publié un texte sur sa page facebook
remarquable dans lequel il raconte les
souffrances
avec des verbatim de personnes deux
femmes un espèce de sa circonscription
qui sont allés dans les cités aux barres
d'immeubles et il les interpellations
toler qui racontent leurs difficultés
mais comment ne pas donner à voir cela
ne serait ce que pour que les gens qui
en souffrent et bien se sentent
considérés au minimum je serais mort sur
lcp on essaye de montrer cette cette
réalité de tous les électeurs reportage
tourné dans dans la campagne des
législatives en moselle sur le marché
die anges aux côtés du candidat laurent
jacobellis avant son élection à
l'assemblée c'est signé thibault enock
et clément perreault regardez
ici hayange en moselle il y a quelques
semaines c'est aux côtés du maire est
reine de la ville que le candidat aux
législatives laurent jacobellis fait
campagne à ses toits qui me guide
tous deux sont sur le terrain depuis des
années maintenant
l'implantation du r n est l'un des
atouts stratégiques qui a permis au
parti de franchir une étape à ces
législatives les cercles concentriques
qui on va dire c'est dire que quand il
ya une commune qui est bien gérée comme
ici à hayange c'est la preuve par
l'exemple de ce que c'est que le rn et
donc du coup évidemment dans les
communes autour a les gens ont une bonne
image ils connaissent le travail du
maire du coup ça peut amener des voix
pour les autres élections de fait dans
cet ancien bassin minier marquée par la
désindustrialisation
les deux hommes sont en terrain conquis
certains électeurs se cachent bien
encore un peu avec fabien je mal vers
l'ailleurs
mais la plupart plus du tout même ses
policiers municipaux semblent acquis à
la cause ce maire comment savoir
face à cet électorat en grande partie
conquis le candidat n'a plus qu'à
répéter un message en boucle ce qu'il
faut dit le bien autour de vous c'est
que les gens aillent voter au final
rares sont ceux qui émettent encore des
critiques envers le et rennes tous ceux
qui sont d'origine française laissant en
vrai dans son pays il y en a qui
cendrier qui ont des enfants et là
encore le discours se veut immédiatement
ratio c'est exactement pas ce qui se
passera à monsieur si vous êtes si vous
avez le droit d'être en france
d'abord si vous êtes français aucun
problème dimanche dernier laurent
jacobellis a été élu avec 52 4% des voix
dominique reynié cette france qui a peur
du déclassement qui a peur de
l'immigration qui s'inquiètent de
l'insécurité à l'est documenté ya
énormément de recherches vous avez
travaillé là dessus qu'est ce qui
explique au fond que elle ne trouve pas
d'autre offre que le rassemblement
national est ce que c'est le
rassemblement national qui s'adressent à
elle est plus personne d'autre c'est ça
qui s'est lui parler oui et c'est un des
aspects du drame je trouve de notre
société qui est que quand cette france
qui votent et rennes autrefois fn on la
connaît bien c'est une france populaire
ce sont des retraités pauvres ce sont
des revenus très modestes des personnes
qui n'ont pas fait beaucoup d'études qui
sont plutôt à la périphérie les ouvriers
principalement ou s'abstiennent ou
votent et rennes les petites classes
moyennes bref des personnes qu'elle et
les autres formations politiques ont
démissionné vis-à-vis de ces classes là
je pense qu'il y à une sorte de
préférence par facilité pour des groupes
sociaux qui ne sont pas aussi attaché à
régler des problèmes comme l'immigration
la sécurité qui impressionne je dirais
les responsables par par la taille de
l'enjeu mais ce qui est ce qui est
dramatique c'est que ces personnes qui
votent fn sont des personnes issues de
milieux modestes donc elles ne sont pas
elles n'ont pas de représentants et non
pas de clé à n'ont pas de d'orateur
elles ne savent pas comment faire ses
ailes sont démunis et donc le fait que
autrefois le parti communiste français
pour dire les choses d'un point de vue
historique et et leur porte-parole
principale est remarquable elles se sont
retrouvées abandonnées elles ont eu le
sentiment qu'on les a abandonnés ou
qu'on les trahissent et il ya plusieurs
dimensions et le front national puis
leur assemblée nationale se sont occupés
de les représenter avec succès alors
aujourd'hui elles sont représentées à
l'assemblée et de quelle manière on voit
très bien que marine le pen veut
s'institutionnaliser il ya toute une
stratégie de la respectabilité regarder
cette image c'était aujourd'hui marine
le pen élue à la tête de ce groupe de 89
députés plutôt acclamé
[Musique]
voilà marine le pen à la tête de ce
groupe elle se veut au fond l'anti
lentilles insoumise des manières elle
construit une marque en opposition
totale au niveau de la nuque elle leur a
demandé une tenue correcte la cravate
elle leur a demandé de travailler d'être
une opposition elle dit constructives
même et sérieuse est ce que vous croyez
à cette institutionnalisation là à cette
parlementarisation du rassemblement
national alors
à l'absorption de la culture
parlementaire ça c'est à voir parce que
la culture parlementaire c'est une
culture de la modération du compromis ça
a été beaucoup dit c'est très juste donc
ça cette demande à voir par contre
le fait d'avoir choisi d'être présidente
du groupe alors que jean luc mélenchon
n'a même pas eu la bonne idée c'est une
erreur majeure d'être candidat à la
députation une nouvelle fois alors que
vous le disiez
il y à il ya une espèce de nouveaux
coeurs battants que sera pendant
quelques temps l'assemblée nationale je
ne sais pas d'ailleurs avec quelle durée
avec un résultat bien sûr c'est une
occasion absolument à nord pour marine
le pen de montrer qu'elle est à la fois
le premier groupe de l'opposition
une expression de l'opposition forte qui
n'est pas celle d'une opposition je
dirais braillarde qui va faire du
happening régulièrement et qui se
distingue évidemment parce que elle a
une trajectoire qui y compris en avril
dernier l'a souvent tour de la
présidentielle avec un résultat
historique même si elle a été battue
largement
41,35 % c'est un résultat historique
c'est une personne qui représente 13
millions d'électeurs et donc elle va
devenir je pense mécaniquement une
figure notabilisé elle va même elle même
je pense que ça elle va se changer sa
valeur de faire de parler à laura d elle
aura des ddd des conseillers alors un
entourage de meilleure qualité j'imagine
donc on va avoir peu à peu le sentiment
qu'elle est capable et déjà avant ça
elle est à 41 45 % auquel a une marge de
progression c'est ce que vous nous dites
et avec cette assemblée nationale une
forme de l'ultime étape de normalisation
va suivre sans merci beaucoup merci
merci dominique reynié parce que on a
besoin d'eux de votre expertise puisque
ils sont maintenant député 89 on va on
va suivre la manière dont il vous
légiférez c'est l'heure d'accueillir à
présent nos a franchi pour leur parti
pris ce soir déjà mon d'un gars va nous
racontent toutes les tractations en
cours pour les postes clés à l'assemblée
nationale on va accueillir également le
grand reporter vincent et jeu qui va
nous parler du retour en grâce de mbs
mohamed ben salman prince d'arabie
saoudite et puis l'oeil sur le numérique
de dasri sabatier se pose ce soir sur la
mode à l'intelligence artificielle de
google capable de ressentir les émotions
j'en frissonne aux affranchis les voici
bonsoir bon sens là tous les trois ravis
de vous accueillir l on commence avec
vous vous suivez l'installation de cette
nouvelle assemblée avec ce matin un
nouveau chef pour les socialistes
oui c'est un visage connu puisque ce
sera boris vallot le député des landes a
été préféré ce matin à guillaume garot
lors d'un vote au sein du groupe boris
vannes oc son deuxième mandat il prend
la tête donc d'un groupe d'une trentaine
de députés un groupe indépendant mais
dans une coalition de gauche la nuque
écoutez il ya beaucoup de choses que
nous pouvons porter et porté avec nos
partenaires mais avec une initiative qui
peut être jours donc affirmer ce que
nous sommes dans une union de la gauche
comme le feront les communistes comme le
feront les écologistes comme le feront
les insoumis alors juste à côté de lui
il y avait l'ancien président du groupe
socialiste valérie rabault elle n'était
pas candidate à sa succession elle dit
vouloir retourner à ses premières amours
la finance chacun ses loisirs tiens
tiens justement il va y avoir une grosse
bataille ici à l'assemblée la semaine
prochaine ce sera pour la présidence de
la commission des finances un oui lors à
elle est extrêmement convoité cette
présidence tout le monde la veut elsa
que dit précisément la règle et que dit
précisément lusage alors dans le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale la
seule précision c'est que la présidence
de la commission des finances eh bien on
doit aller un député d'un groupe
d'opposition c'est tout ce qui est dit
ensuite lusage veut que le groupe
majoritaire ne prennent pas part au vote
donc par conséquence c'est le plus gros
groupes d'opposition qui gagne à la fin
don pour le rassemblement national c'est
clair elle lui revient à écouter
pourquoi parce que ce premier parti
d'opposition un rassemblement
international on changerait tout ce
serait ne pas respecter nos électeurs ne
pas respecter le verdict des urnes il
est naturel légitime et normal que la
présidence de cette commission ne
revienne sauf que là et on en a parlé on
est dans une configuration inédite à
l'assemblée nationale puisqu'il ya une
coalition à gauche et si elle se met
d'accord sur une candidature commune et
bien le pourrait ravir cette présidence
alors c'était au menu un du premier
intergroupe de la nuque ou nubes d'une
réunion avec les représentants des
insoumis des socialistes des écologistes
et des communistes ils sont tous
d'accord pour ne faire que deux
candidatures communes écouter matile pas
d'où on vous laisse un peu de surprises
sinon c'est pas drôle et nous aurons à
un nom en commun comme pour toutes les
autres fonctions de l'assemblée motif
ils sont d'accord sur le principe pas
encore sur les non évidemment on sent
que la majorité est assez de stresser
sur l'attribution de ce poste elle
semble absolument opposé à ce que les
insoumis en hérite oui c'est la hantise
de la majorité voire à un affreux
anticapitaliste prendre la tête de cette
commission ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est
que le président de la commission des
finances il a quand même beaucoup de
pouvoir il a un pouvoir de contrôle sur
place et sur pièce par exemple il peut
arriver à bercy un matin demandé de
documents l'administration ne peut pas
lui opposer le secret fiscal alors lui
est censé garder le secret fiscal mais
bon il peut y avoir éventuellement des
fuites il peut aussi avoir une incidence
sur l'organisation de l'examen du budget
donc on voit que c'est quand même un
rôle très important pour certains de
l'ale droite notamment voirin a soumis à
cette place ça relève du cauchemar
quitte à laisser penser et bien qu'on
préférerait avoir un candidat du
rassemblement national à la présidence
de la commission des finances ce sera
les élections mercredi prochain et on va
suivre ça de très près et incroyable à
la majorité qui préférerait presque un
candidat et rennes à la commission des
finances affaire à suivre vingt ans on
va parler avec vous ce soir du retour en
grâce spectaculaire et inattendue de
mohamed ben slama ben salman le prince
saoudien donc c'est vrai dans l'arène
internationale tout est possible les
voltes faces les plus brutales les
zigzags les plus déroutants et sur ce
registre la vie en turquie du prince
héritier d'arabie saoudite mohammad ben
salman al yah cmbs mérite un oscar le 2
octobre 2018 le dissident saoudien jamal
khashoggi connu pour les éditos incisif
que publie le washington post franchi le
seuil du consulat du royaume wahhabite à
ankara démarche anodine un en amont de
son mariage avec sa fiancée turc il n'en
sortira jamais ni vivant ni entier cible
d'un traquenard racho ji est assassiné
par un commando de tueurs qui débite son
cadavre à la disqueuse aussitôt le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
accusent les plus hauts échelons du
régime saoudien suivez son regard
d'avoir commandité le massacre mieux
ankara diffuse
enregistrement de cet hallali commis
dans une enceinte consulaires truffé de
micros moins de quatre ans plus tard air
doit elle choisit donc de passer cet
épisode atroce à l'ardoisé magique on
efface tout en avril la justice turque
ou ce qui en tient lieu seuls 2 le
procès par contumace de la vingtaine de
saoudiens incriminés et transfère le
dossier acquis aux autorités du royaume
suivront une escapade arias depuis hier
mercredi la réception de mbs avec parade
équestre et garde d'honneur moralité si
j'ose dire il est plus facile d'enterrer
une infamie que la dépouille d'un
opposant si jamal avec une tombe soupire
sa compagne cathy jay hill si
retournerait alors comment on explique
ce changement qui est complet splendeurs
et misères de la realpolitik aux prises
avec une monnaie en chute libre et une
inflation démentent le sultan ardoines
voit approcher dans moins d'un an
l'occurrence un scrutin présidentiel à
haut risque autant dire que les
investissements en pétrodollars sont les
bienvenus ardemment souhaité lui le
mentor et les des frères musulmans voilà
qu'il se rabiboche avec les états vous
en cette mouvance islamiste aux gémonies
à commencer par l'egypte du maréchal
président el sissi et donc la monarchie
des saoud il n'est pourtant pas le seul
à ouvrir et à la réhabilitation de
haut que non en décembre dernier à la
faveur d'une tournée régionale emmanuel
macron a fait escale à jeddah pour
rencontrer le très impulsif mbs aussi
avide de moderniser son royaume quand
klein à bâillonner toute voix
contestataire
le locataire de l'elysée premier
dirigeant occidental à saluer le prince
sur ses terres le premier certes mais
pas le dernier jo leinen soi-même
limitera à la mi-juillet dire qu'à peine
élu le tombeur de trump avait autorisé à
la diffusion d'un rapport secret des
renseignements américains établissant
que le prince trentenaire avait bel et
bien validé je cite la liquidation de
l'éditorialiste insoumis là encore un
seul principe prévaut le principe de
réalité
la nécessité de contenir les a pity
régionaux de l'iran ennemi juré dryades
et l'impact de l'agression russe en
ukraine sur le marché des hydrocarbures
relègue aux oubliettes le martyre sur
ordre de rachel j en d'autres termes
c'est au nom des cours du brut
selon ce qu'on a tenu de faire la cour à
la brute merci quelques chutes merci
merci infiniment
vincent delphine vous souhaitiez revenir
ce soir sur une polémique autour de
l'intelligence artificielle qui
ressentiraient des émotions humaines je
vais vous expliquer donc la sphère
démarre en fait dans les laboratoires de
google on a affaire un programme qui
vise à améliorer grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle des outils automatiques de
conversation c'est quand vous posez des
questions à votre smartphone ou votre
enceinte connecter si vous en avez une
il faut que le logiciel ils comprennent
votre demande et puis faut surtout
qu'ils sachent vous répondre de manière
explicite et fuite sinon c'est
totalement raté donc là google a prouvé
qu'il avait très bien travaillé dans ce
domaine
démonstration en écoute
là on entend en fait une femme poser une
question à un logiciel google a appris à
ce logiciel a répond comme s'il était un
avion en papier la femme lui demande en
gros va ça fait quoi d'être jetés comme
ça dans les airs et là on entend le
logiciel qui répond à la première
personne qui évoque des sensations comme
sentir l'air contre soi il va même
jusqu'à inventer ce qui aurait été le
pire atterrissage de sa vie dont c'est
très troublant mais ça c'était déjà en
2021 donc là on est un an après et
quelques jours donc coup d'éclat
puisqu'on a un ingénieur de google qui
seule alerte et qui dit qu'en fait le
logiciel sur lequel on lui a demandé de
travailler et bien ce serait vraiment
doué d'émotion il en est tellement
persuadé est tellement bouleversée
d'ailleurs qui le réclame qu'on accorde
des droits à cette intelligente d'armes
officielle comme un être humain
finalement que des google alors à ce
sujet alors au bac absolument rien ne
permet aujourd'hui d'attester qu'on
serait face à une ia car une conscience
d'elle-même qui seraient sensibles 1 to
prove plutôt même le contraire un
consensus aujourd'hui
scientifique pour dire que les logiciels
de conversation ce sont surtout des
machines qui sont entraînés habitué à
créer des phrases à partir de milliards
de mots d'humains qui ont été compilés
savamment agencés donc oui ces robots
conversationnel peuvent sembler parfois
intelligents peuvent même nous
surprendre parce qu'ils font des
connexions assez inédite avec
différentes données mais ce ne sont que
des logiciels quand on leur prête une
conscience on fait de
l'anthropomorphisme mais il ya quand
même un peu de quoi s'inquiéter ou pas
alors en fait plutôt que de jouer à se
faire peur avec cia qui prendrait vie il
faut effectivement commencé à
s'inquiéter des effets qu'elles
produisent sur nous comme avec cet
ingénieur finalement qui ça reste des
robots mais ils finissent par nos voilà
il se rendre un peu à votre propre exact
crois malgré qu'elle provoque sur nous
parce qu'on s'identifie tellement on
identifie tellement la machine à l'homme
que c'en est troublant voit donc cet
ingénieur qui a qui a développé une
empathie vraiment très forte pour ce
logiciel avec lequel ils conversaient la
professeure en intelligence artificielle
au cnrs laurence devillers nous dit
qu'il est urgent de se mettre tous
autour de la table pour
cent ans sur des normes éthiques pour
tout le secteur et des comités d'experts
indépendants et c'est vrai qu'on peut
pas laisser comme ça se concevoir des
logiciels de conversation qui sème la
confusion finalement dans nos esprits
qui joue sur le registre des émotions
avec n'est une régulation vous et croyez
pas mal oui il faut un cadre éthique ça
c'est évident et puis surtout faut
attribuer des responsabilités
donc à google en particulier un petit
robot à la maison sa version passe
moderne de la rose et le réséda de louis
aragon celui qui croyait au logiciel
celui qui n'y croyaient pas très joli
bravo 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace soit si
ces salles espoirs 1 la machine qui vous
fait même si à la mine s'est
séparé du fantasme qui nous font peur
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
premiers problèmes se posent et c'est
pas tellement d y en a qui seraient
surpuissant qui nous dépasse rai 1 c'est
nous comment on se fait ou non trompé
par ses logiciels qui ne sont que des
logiciels parfois c'est tellement
troublant qu'on peut être aussi assez
fragile face à la machine absolument
tout quand on est en détresse manuel
macro il aimerait peut-être avoir un
logiciel à il pourrait lui poser la
question comment obtenir des majorités
absolues ici à l'assemblée non merci à
vous alors des algorithmes qui tourne
mensuel et persil et d'accrocher mois
s'arrêter là c'est la fin de cette
émission va se retrouver demain pour une
nouvelle émission ça vous regarde tout
de suite votre soirée documentaire ce
soir un film sur les chauffeurs routiers
victimes du dumping social en europe les
routes de la discorde si et brian carter
suivie d'un débat autour de jean pierre
gratien et son invité le patron de la
cfdt laurent berger très belle soirée à
demain
[Musique]